We're coming up on five years. I know, isn't that amazing? So then how many episodes is that? We've been doing one week for five years. We're gonna be 250 episodes in, I don't know. And 25 is the silver, 50 is the gold. Is there anything for 250? Is that triple silver?
It's, What is it? What is it centennial? Wasn't it like- Wait guys, this is our 250th episode. Also known as- Come on. 250th! Bravo, bravo!
Bravo! Welcome guys, so nice to be here. Oh, you came from the back of the theater. Yeah, I came. I finally made it my way to the front. Nice to see you guys. Look at you guys. Anyway, hey listen, do you mind if I drop some beats on you? That'd be okay.
Let me tell you something about, just close Riviera, 1982, white Ferrari Mondial. Puff, puff, screaming down the autostrada. You have a cenzano with eyes. Okay, now you're feeling the vibe, huh? Listen, let me ask you something. When you're making a podcast, everybody wants to know what's that old-fashioned recipe. But one thing, one favore, testa ligare, svitato, what I'm trying to say is, smile Huh? Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la Hey!
Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la Whatever! Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la I love you! Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Oh!
Ba-la, ba-la If you want to do one thing in this year, get Smiless250. Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Shani, have you been a... Do one thing in this year, get Smiles 250. 250th. Shawnee, how have you been? It's been a minute. My nephew and his girlfriend and three friends are visiting in town this weekend, which is super fun.
Wait, are we going to see them tonight? No, I know. I think it's too many people. Right. So you're not going to go. Am I going to see you tonight? No. What? I know, I think it's too many people. Right. So you're not gonna go. Am I gonna see you tonight? No. What?
I know, it's gonna be bad. But I don't get to see my nephew and everybody. I feel bad. You saw them last night, right? Why don't you come over here afterwards? That'll never happen. Oh yeah, that'll happen. Hey, yeah, Jason, why don't you come over there afterwards? Right around 8.. Oh yeah, that'll happen. Hey, yeah, Jason, why don't you come over there afterwards?
Right around 8.30 or something, drive across the city and spend another two hours. This will happen for sure. Yeah, but last night, I took him to Koi, right, last night? Sure you did. And I was. Oh yeah, your favorite tea food restaurant. It was so good, and I was walking back to the car
and there was a pothole that I thought was just like a surface puddle and it was a massive pothole and I completely twisted my ankle. It was so fucking painful. Look at that. Is it all swollen? Yeah, it's huge. Come here, bubbins.
Well, you can't see it, it's huge. No, I can see that. You iced it. This is gonna heal fast, right? Like I freaked out last night. Probably not, it'll probably heal the wrong way and you'll be clubbed. Do you know the term clubfoot?
Deadfoot. Well, but fortunately it's not going to take anything away from your life. Usually it means that you can't be playing basketball or doing all the jogging and all that stuff. Luckily you don't do any of it. Yeah, that's true. Is that what you're getting at, Jason?
Yeah, you'll still be able to shuffle into chin chin for lunch and koi for dinner. Shuffle. What if you go to the doctor and you're like, will this affect my ability to watch TV all day? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, no, I just prop it up on the couch. That's what I've been doing. Will I still be able to chop celery into my egg salad? No tuna salad. Well, I have to cut my sloppy Joe intake.
You know what though, here's the deal. They went to the Tar Pits, you know the La Brea Tar Pits near the museum. They being your nephew. My nephew and girlfriend and their friends. Is that still a tourist attraction here? It is, they've never been. And they bought crickets.
They bought a bag of crickets and they ate them. Sour cream and onion crickets. And they pulled them out. What does that have to do with the, okay, go ahead. Because they're saying the dinosaurs used to eat crickets back in the tar pit days. Why do they sell those? No, no, no, no, no, they sell them in the gift shop.
They sell them in the gift shop. Why? I have no idea. At the museum? Yes, and they pulled them, you want one? I'm like, no, I'm not gonna eat a cricket. Oh God. Why not?
The last time I heard crickets was Good Night Oscar. It was right after the curtain went down. But that's a... Look at him, he's on fire today. He's on fuego. Who would do the worst at some sort of like outdoor survivor type of show where you got a guy I'd last two seconds I'd last no, but I think I wouldn't I think I might do even worse
Well, you would call your lawyer and say am I obligated to eat this Imagine if we took the word obligation out of your vocabulary you weren't allowed to his obligation Yeah, I mean I need new shtick. I'm sick of my own fucking voice. I'm going to be silent today on the podcast. We love your voice. I miss both you guys a lot. I know, I haven't seen you.
I'm so bummed I'm not going tonight. I've been in New York and I've been with lots of friends and lots of people and obviously with Bradley, but I really miss you guys a lot. I know, likewise. I miss you too. I was thinking about you this morning. I'm so jealous. I miss you too. I think I really did. I'm so jealous, I can't see you.
Anyway, here we go. Speaking of can't wait to see people, I can't wait for you to see our guest today. Oh, great opening line. This person is someone we all, thank you, thank you. She's someone we all know well. So much so that I'm not sure what I can say about her
that won't give it away. But she's a prolific comedian, she's an author, super producer, really great director. She played Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz when she was 10. And more recently, I think she played Elphaba in the movie Wicked, I don't know. A Boston, she didn't. A Boston native, her summer job was working
at an ice cream parlor where she'd sing Happy Birthday with Kazooz. Today she's a comedic force in Hollywood. Hilarious, colleague! And the world's favorite cool mom, the Regina George, is our ridiculously funny friend, Amy Poehler. No way! Wait, truly?
I feel invited, I guess so! Well, well, well. Wait a second! Holy shit! Well, well, well. Wait a second. First of all, how many levels am I involved in? Wait a second. Holy shit. Well, well, well. Wait a second. First of all, how many levels am I?
I know, this is what, of course my first question is, did you know about this? And of course. No. Okay, good, I love it. Not a glimpse of recognition on Will's face when you said all of those things. There's no way that I thought, well, I knew that you worked at Brigham's,
but I didn't in Boston. Chadwick's, Will. Oh, Chadwick. you worked at Brigham's, but I didn't, in Boston. Chadwick's, Will, I worked at Chadwick's. No, sorry. Unbelievable. But we went to Brigham's with your dad and he asked the people if they liked their job. Yeah, let him finish, Amy. Yeah.
I can't believe this. Wait, Amy, did you have to, because of kid stuff, did you have to like say, oh, I can't, or whatever, or some schedule stuff and lie or something? You know what, it was really easy to hide it. Nobody was asking if I was doing it. Okay. Do you think Archie and Abel would have been able
to keep the secret? Did you not tell them? Well, I think one of them knew. One of them knew. One of them saw, our youngest saw my schedule on the kitchen table and said, you're doing smart lists. Oh wow. Does dad know?
No way. And I said, no, don't say anything. I love it. People kept the secret. It's so cool. Wait, and also Amy and I were texting last night about something else, zero. That's good, that's good.
That is unbelievable. I can't. Amy, I didn't know what to say. I didn't know how to introduce you without them not following it. Sean, I'm so honored to be your guest, Sean, of all three. Likewise. First of all, I've asked her to do it and she said no,
and then she said yes to Sean. Well, I wanted to wait until you had done 250 episodes to see if this thing was real. Wait, really? I know we've been trying to get you on for so long, and it's so kind of worked out. Well, I usually give something five years before I try it. Sure, sure.
Bob. Wait, Will, how many times have you asked her to do it? A couple times. I asked you to do it on tour, I think, right, Amy? Yeah, I think so, yeah. But, you know, it just had to, I just was waiting, I was waiting for my buddy Sean to give me the go ahead.
Here I am, here I am. I gave her the green light and she showed up. Like a race car. Hang on one second, hang on. Amanda, get over here. What? Um, but wait, Sean, did you think for a second, like wait, should I, is this cool?
Like did you ask Bennett or Rob to like kind of float it by will to see if that. Yeah, no, I mean, Amy's been on my list. What are you guys talking about? Why do you have to float anything past anybody? Well, we kind of do that every once in a while. Guys, nice, by the way, great welcome. Nice to see you all. Hi.
I mean, Jesus, you're all talking about how weird it is that I'm here. Hi, I'm your guest. Nice to see you. Oh, hi. Good Lord. First of all, you can't take over our podcast. You can't tell us.
No, it's the only way to talk on this podcast is to completely take it over. 100%. Believe me. It's unbearable if the guest doesn't, because you make us sit and listen to you in the beginning anyway. And it's torturous. It's torturous. It's unbearable if the guest doesn't. Because you make us sit and listen to you in the beginning anyway. And it's torturous.
It's torturous. It's unbelievable. What do you think about how- And every single time I hear you guys talk about how much you miss each other. And am I wrong that you talk to each other every week? No, this is it. We don't get to see each other.
We don't get to see each other. First of all, slow down. I'm outraged like five outrages ago. Okay? This is so great. Wait, wait, for Tracy, just so, just to really air, right, for my sister. Of course.
You guys were married and now you're not and it's been years and years. Everything's going swimmingly. What a great way to put it. Anyway, let me be the first to say welcome to Smart Music. Thank you, thank you. We're 17 minutes in, but thank you for that. Amy, this is so great.
And great crickets joke, by the way, Will. That was a really good crickets joke. That was a good one. Very, very smart, very sharp. Thank you. Jason, are you okay with your mic? Yeah, I'm having a real mic issue this morning. Is it bad for you guys?
Is this bad for me? No, it sounds great. It sounds fine. Now, so Amy, Will, how did you guys first meet? Yeah, we're gonna get into it. No, we're definitely not. When did it first start to fracture? No, we're definitely not.
We're definitely not. Amy, it first start to fracture? No, we're definitely not. We're definitely not. Amy, can I tell this story about, you and I were talking about, about Sedaris the other day. Oh yeah, that's a good, yeah, that's a very funny story. So, and I think I maybe told it once before, but you guys- Great, great Amy Sedaris story. So Amy Sedaris, who's working with us on the film,
I was hanging out with her the other day, and she, years ago, Amy Poehler and Amy Sedaris would often get mixed up for each other, because they're both comedians, and they're both sort of blonde and kind of, you know. Cute and funny and talented and charming. Fun and sassy. And I've been with Poehler a million times where people would say to, remember,
they'd go like, I'm such a fan of your brother. And you're like, oh, he's a lawyer, thank you. He'll really appreciate that. I mean, so, so, so I guess it happened to Sedaris too. And one time, like 20 years ago, I read this article in a magazine where Sedaris says, people come up to me all the time and say, oh my God, I love you so great.
And I'm such a, you know, I just love you and Will, and Sedera says in the interview, and I usually say to them like, yeah, Will and I are having a lot of sexual problems. Which is so funny. Yeah, that is really funny. Oh, look at Bless, he's really having an issue. Bateman's really having, it's so fascinating
that he's having microphone problems. Will, Sean, tell her what it's like when I have technical issues. It's not good. I'm going to slam the laptop in a second. What's wrong? We hear you great. We had McConaughey on once and he was in the blind
and Jason was having issues and it took 20 minutes and he got so mad and he was like fuck it and he started freaking out and McConaughey starts laughing with his camera covered. And Jason goes, oh, it's really funny, is it? Who's laughing? Who's laughing? That's not helpful. And he slammed his...
And I slammed my laptop like a bitch. Wow. Yeah. It was not all right, all right, all right, is what you're saying. No. It was not all right, all right. Oh!
So Amy, how did you start in comedy? Yeah. Oh, believe me, we're getting into that. We're getting into that. Oh, right. So Amy, how did you start in comedy? Yeah. Oh, believe me, we're getting into that. We're getting into that. Oh, Lord, you guys with your questions, they're so good. First of all, your questions are always so good. Right? So sought out.
We're up for, as you would call it, a Peabody. A Peabody. A Peabody. Amy, how was, can we talk about? Good reference. Can we, how was the, we talk about... Good reference. How was the... Was SNL 50 fun?
Because that show was great. Oh man, it was so fun. It was kind of... You were so great on it. It was kind of out of body. Like it was kind of too... It was almost too big. Like, like celeb fatigue almost.
Yeah. But it was so fun. And I think it was a big success. Yeah, it was a great show. I started thinking about all the SUVs that must have been choking out midtown. Like how do they get... You want me to give you a scoop?
You want me to give you a smartless scoop? Like a... Yeah. Making news. Breaking news. People had to share dressing rooms and I shared mine with Meryl Streep. Wow. How cool is that? Is she a dirty bathroom girl?
Does she keep the top off the toothpaste? Well, SNL, you don't have your own bathroom. You have like a, you know, it is a straight up, everyone uses like a hall bathroom. You don't have your own bathroom in your own dressing room at SNL. Do people still smoke back there? No, I didn't see anybody smoking. Maybe vaping, but yeah. But yeah, maybe you could. Do people still smoke back there? No, I didn't see anybody smoking. Just Dave Chappelle. Maybe vaping, but yeah.
But yeah, maybe you could if you just did it. I bet no one would stop you. Was she a good dressing room partner? The loveliest. We were kind of two ships, but I took a picture of the door because it was nice to have my... I love that sketch she did.
I know, so funny. Her and Kate, Kate is so... I mean, could she have hiked those jeans up higher? I mean, it was just tough. Just tough. But it was so fun. It felt like a high school reunion. Everybody regressed a little bit back into their old roles.
Isn't that fun? And it was fun. It was, you know, I can't believe I was there, to be very honest. Like, it was wild. You and Tina were great in your bit. Yeah, you and Tina, I loved it. That was a great bit. It was, you know, I can't believe I was there, to be very honest. Like it was wild. You and Tina were great in your bit. Yeah, you and Tina, I loved it. That was amazing. That was a great bit.
That was so good. Thanks. For Tracy Tina Fey. So listen, Amy, when you... Yeah, I think she's fucking... Tracy's got it, bro. Sean, you treat Tracy like she's getting dumber. I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding. Amy, tell a little bit, wait, just you guys,
and then you and Maya did Bronx Beat, which is an all time favorite. Hilarious. Can you tell, these guys probably don't know where Bronx Beat came from, the origin story of it. Oh yeah, the story of that is there's an amazing the head of the hair department, Jody Mancuso, is from the Bronx and she has that accent
and she would just work with us in the hair and makeup room and we just started talking like her. So there's a real Jodi, so when we do the show we always go into the hair room and just have Jodi be like our vocal dialect coach. Yeah, get us there. I love that. Have you ever thought about bringing her on the sketch?
Yeah, but you know, it's funny that we brought Donna, the dresser, on for that moment. And those, the crew, like they're so, you know, real professionals like don't care about being on camera. Right. Yeah, yeah. Like a really actual good professional could give a shit if they're like an actor acting. Except for Wally.
Wally loves it, Wally does love it. Wally loves it. Yeah, Wally the cute guy. The, Wally does love it. Wally loves it. Yeah, Wally the Cupid guy. The stage manager. But I said professional, I said professional. Exactly. But Amy, being back, doing that 50th like that, like you said, it's like a reunion.
I think I asked you a long, long, long time ago when you departed the show and you decided to leave, that I was like, won't you miss like that? I thought you were kicked off. Sorry, I had a different. I was asked to leave. I was making people uncomfortable. That's why.
You were given the opportunity to retire. Well, I had a very gentle HR meeting where a man in a suit put me on an elevator, Severin style, and I don't remember what happened since. Do they have an HR on the show? Because if so, that's got to be a really high-trafficked office. Well, they do. They do have an HR. And they do, like all of the shows that we've all worked on,
you know, I mean, do you remember? And do we still have to go through the, you know, all that training every time, which is very good to do. But yeah, it is. I believe that they do that still, and should. It's probably a very different environment than I was there 20 plus years ago for all of us.
But when you, like, you're one of the all-time greats to ever be on SNL. And it is true, it's true. I mean, everybody's great, but there's breakouts. I really like her style! Oh, somebody's trying to do that. She's a fan-tastic. What about the after party?
Was there a good, there must have been a very robust after party for this one. Yeah, robust after party at the Plaza Hotel. Whoa, was there an after-after with the little? There may have been, I didn't hang that long. I love bedtime. I used to be a vampire and now I love bedtime. I think about bedtime all day.
Do they still do the little sort of, the size of like a fortune and a cookie, hand a little address for the after-after party? Is that still something that's done? I feel like one of the things that was different is things are texted and emailed, and I didn't have any of that when I was there wildly. We didn't even have phones
that we carried around on the floor. I mean, maybe we did occasionally, but we would kind of leave them in the dressing room, but now everything is texted. So I imagine maybe it's a text now. Maybe it's a Snapchat or some kind of YouTube channel people subscribe to. Maybe it's probably a podcast that tells you what we're the after-afters. You have to tune in.
Speaking of pods, you've got a new pod on, Amy. Oh my God, thank you so much for that. Tell us about your new pod. Oh, that's why she's here. Hi. Yeah, that's right she's here. That's right. Yeah, that's right. What's it called? And where can we find it?
Good Hang with Amy Poehler. It's called Good Hang, and it's on Spotify. Yes, can't wait. And I'm very excited. It's been really fun. We've been recording and getting ready for our launch. I don't know when this show is going to come on, when this one drops.
How far ahead are you guys? July of 2026. Okay, July 2026. So it's been going for about a year and it's been good. This is a good bump, this will be a good bump. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
But wait, but Amy, I was going to ask you if you ever wanted to do sketch comedy again because going back to what I was saying before, you're one of the all-time greats and it's hard to find people that can do what you do and Kristen Wiig does and Maya and Tina and all these really breakout people can do. And so, but every time I see you do it, I'm like,
ooh, I just wish you would go, like do more sketch. Because I fell in. But go back how? What do you mean? Do a sketch show? That's a lot of work. I know, but so you're like, ooh, it's nap time, bed time. It just feels like, I know what you mean, Shawn.
I love doing it. I just don't know if I could launch back into an actual full-time sketch show. It's so much work. And creating the material, generating the material is so time consuming. But I love it. As a fan, I think I speak for a lot of people. Like, oh, we see you and everybody together.
Well, we're not really taking questions from fans right now. But Amy, do you don't still do, you don't really still do like ask at her there's no version of that anymore. No improv. But you know, Tina and I have been on tour. We've been we've done our show a bunch of cities last year going back out again in March, April and May for you know, if you're in Orlando, do you have some dates you want to talk about? Yeah, we have Orlando, we have Detroit, Chicago, Boston, playing Red Rocks. Wow, no shit. Red Rocks. Yeah, we have Orlando, we have Detroit, we have Chicago, Boston, playing Red Rocks.
Wow, no shit, Red Rocks. Yeah, yeah. That's cool. Is it written or is it improvised? Yeah, so it's written. It's like a long variety show. We have special guests come in. We kind of go through the history of our 30-year friendship.
But there's a section in it that where we talk about Chicago and how we met and so we improvise there, which is really fun. Yes, I want to talk about that because I did Second City too and you did too. Yeah. And I never performed on the main stage, but you. Same.
Oh wow. So people think you're probably from Chicago all the time, but you're from Boston. Yeah, people think I'm from the Midwest a lot because also with Parks and Rec, their head goes to Indiana, so people think I'm from the Midwest a lot because also with Parks and Rec, their head goes to Indiana, so they think I'm like a Chicago. Would you consider yourself like a Boston homegirl?
I mean, I'm definitely a homie. How is Bill Pola? Tell us how Bill Pola is. Let's talk about Bill. Can we talk about Bill for a minute? Oh God, he'd love it. So this is- He'd like us to talk for an hour.
This is, he would. So this is the reason I got Chadwick's and Brigham's mixed up. I just want to tell this story, if I could. We can always cut it, Aym, by the way, which is... We don't cut anything on this show. We went to... No, I can tell. There's no editing.
This is super baggy. We go to Brigham's, which is an ice cream store in the mall in Burlington, Mass., which is where Amy's from, with her mom and dad. Well, with her dad. And there's this girl, she's like, I don't know, 17, working there as like her afternoon, weekend job, scooping ice cream. This is when Amy's first on SNL.
And her dad goes, like, you know, 25 years, he goes, goes to the girl, just kind of silent, and he goes, you like your job? And she goes, she's like, scooping ice cream. She's like, yeah, I guess so. And he goes, you know who really likes her Jeff my daughter Teed himself up. It was so good
He will get on the elevator with people and say do you like TV and movies? Like like is anyone you're on the elevator with them We played golf. We played golf with these guys years ago, and Bill and I were playing with some random dudes, and he gets back in the car and he looks at me and he goes, Well, I told them. He can't help it. He's so proud though in the best way. I love that.
My parents are like Boston strong, very proud. Retired teachers. Yeah, they watch every SNL, My parents are like Boston strong, very proud. Retired teachers. Yeah, they watch every SNL, they came to every early improv show I ever did live. They had a big watch party for me when our show launched in 1998 on Comedy Central, UCD. They just are very, very big fans.
They're the definition of supportive parents. Like, what you do. Were they the ones that were the first funnies in your family for you? Like, is that where you got your humor from? Yeah, I think, well, I throw this back out to you guys because I think that you probably have families like this too.
You know, you have to kind of keep up. Like, for me, teasing is a love language. If I like you, I can tease you. And manners are kind of for people you don't know or you don't like. So the idea that you could bust each other was a way in which to sharpen your skills. And so we would tease each other.
There was a lot of laughs at the table. It's very Boston Irish. And some families I learned as I went to college, are not that, which is always so shocking to me, when families don't get to poke each other. It's like, oh, okay, it's a different set of rules. You would often accuse, well, first of all, I would say when you say sitting around the table,
let's be honest, it's sitting around the kitchen. Well, let's be honest, it's sitting around the kitchen. Well, let's be honest, it's sitting around the TV. It's sitting around the TV. It was sitting around the TV. But also, you would accuse me of playing too hard that Jason and I would play too hard. Yeah, well, you guys, you guys. It was his deep love, the love was too deep.
You know how they call things a love tap? You guys are a love shove. That's what it's called. You love shove. I love it. I love it. It's good. So it depends on the mood, you know? But I agree with you.
Like, you can meet people and there is that thing of like, if I'm not teasing you... Yeah, we talk about it all the time. I'm not interested in you. Then I'm not really interested. Yeah. Right. In a way.
Yeah, I mean, but some people have a higher and lower tolerance, like, you know, you have to just be a little gentle. But as far as your, I read too, Amy, that you say that you were parentified at a young age. I mean, that like you became your parents because your parents were so young when they had you. Yeah, my parents were young. And don't you feel that way?
Like, I don't know, I don't know, but don't you feel, and this might be just our generation too, I don't know, but don't you feel, and this might be just our generation too, just feel like we felt very old really fast. Like we felt we had freedom, which gave us a sense of agency, and then we had jobs really early, and it just felt like we grew up fast.
I don't know if that's a generational thing, but. Well, Jason, think about it, I'm not joking, was out working when he was, sweet little JB was working when he was seven. I know, bless. So cute, like with a little briefcase and a little security number. And a small mustache.
So you guys, so you both, what I'm interested in, Amy, your background and your parents being school teachers and learning kind of from that, like what did you take from them for Archie and Abel? And Will, what did you take from your parents for Archie and Abel? And how do you do that together? Let me try to bundle that for you.
Amy, do you parent like your parents at all? Oh, by the way, look who's talking. Oh yeah, no, I've been working on it. I've been working with a tutor. You've been working on bundling? Yeah, bundling is sort of a gathering term that he suggested I use internally, but now I'm spreading it. Yeah.
That actually, you could sell a whole bunch of like a series of tapes. I'm just talking about bundling other people's questions. Let me bundle that for you. You could be so successful talking about bundling. If you jumped on a mini trampoline and did a cold dip at the same time, you'd be a bundle king. I think parenting is a constant, ever-changing thing.
Somebody said this to me once that I always loved, which was, parenting is like a series of short stories. So a short story starts and you think, I don't know how this story is gonna go. I don't know the characters. I don't even know what's gonna happen. And then you're in the middle of the short story and you think, man, I never want this to end. I love this, I love this, I got it, I'm in the groove,
I know what I'm doing. And then the short story's over and you think, oh no, there's no way the next one could be better. It's just like a series of, your kid is changing so much and the world is changing so much and you have to stay kind of flexible, pliable, learn from your mistakes. Yeah.
I think the difference for me is, for my own parents is, I have to try really hard, Amy, you're really good at this, and you helped me do this in concert with you, to try to be, to remember to listen to what they're saying and to not try to impose what I think they, you need this, you need that, but to actually sit and listen
to what your kid is trying to say. Like, you know what I mean? Encourage them to, as much as they can to speak and to really hear, and it's not, I don't come by it naturally because that's not how I was raised. Do you know what I mean? Yeah, I am the same.
It doesn't always feel natural. Your instinct is to want to give them advice or tell them what to be aware of or afraid of or share your own personal stuff. That's so instinctual, of course, because we want the best for our kids. And I remember reading somewhere that when your kid tells you something, you
just repeat it back to them like you're doing a headline of a news story. It actually works really well with people too. I bet it happens on this podcast too. They say, oh, I had a bad day in math. And then you go, you had a bad day in math. That's all you say. Period. Yeah. I mean, I'm usually thinking about what the bit is. Like, you know what I mean? But no, but you're right, you're right. And the other day, again, we were talking about something with one of our kids and Amy and I were talking on the phone and I said, oh, I identify with that and I think that my own experience,
and you said to me, you're like, they don't really wanna hear about your experience. They want you to listen to theirs. Yeah, yeah. And don't you feel like this happens as. Yeah, yeah. And we all, this happened, don't you feel like this happens as adults too, when someone talks about like, well, when I used to, you're just like, oh boy.
You know, even in your 50s, it still happens where someone talks about, well, I, you know, in the business I used to be in, we would be able, and you're like, well, that's not the way it is anymore, old man. Right, right, right. It's not that you don't understand. Like, it's so- Yeah, Jason, you must get old man. Right, right. It's not that you don't understand. Yeah, Jason, you must get old man a lot, right?
Yeah, I do a lot more recently. It's pretty shocking. Yeah, I find that it's, I'm constantly battling, like, how much should I be leading this parenting thing, or how much should I be reacting to this parenting thing? In other words, like, should I be waiting to see what thing? In other words, should I be waiting to see
what they need me to parent them at or should I initiate sort of parenting based on nothing they're actually showing me? In other words, should I wait to see until how they react to a certain situation and then talk to them about that? Or this could use a bundle. Yeah, we could bundle this.
Are we still rolling? Could we go back to one? What I think what you're trying to say, yeah. Amy, tell Or this could use a bundle. Yeah, we could bundle this. Are we still rolling? Can we go back to one? What I think what you're trying to say, yeah. Amy, tell, Amy. Let's bundle, let's bundle. Hey, wait, Amy, try to guess what he's trying to say, please. I think the bundle here is how can I be best of service
to my kids. Yes. Thank you. When they're teens, yeah, that's the bundle. That's so good. That's the bundle. But you know, I read something, and by read something, I mean I saw it on TikTok.
Right. There, supposedly when your kids become teens, you go from producer to consultant. That's the difference. You're no longer producing their lives, you're there for them to consult. So you have to kind of let them start producing their own lives, which is not easy.
Not easy. Perfect use of the bundling concept, right? And I've also heard that, you know, part of, like I've heard you love therapy as much as I love therapy. I can talk about it all day long. I love it. I love going to therapy. And because you...
You go to therapy? Yeah. Are you serious? And I'm always trying to make her laugh and she's like, hey, let's get back on topic. But... She's so lucky to have you. You're so funny, Sean. I love you.
Thanks, Annie. You're the funniest. You're the funniest. No, you're the funniest. And so, but you, I've heard, which means I saw on TikTok, that you identify as someone who's a natural fixer, or you want to get into action and problem solve,
because that's kind of how I am a little bit. But as you've gotten older, that you've taught yourself how to pause and feel feelings and stuff like that. And how... Nearly. You got a lot of quotes out there. I do my research, I do my research.
You're talking out loud. You're really living out loud. I sent Sean a bunch of needlepoint pillows with a bunch of stuff on it. And Samian took credit for it. He's going to fill with pillows. I just regurgitate a whole conversation you had on your phone that I overheard. Know that how has that shaped you today?
Because I also read that the best work that you've ever done is the work where you feel most present. Yeah, I think improv was really helpful with that. You had to stay super present just to be, I mean, I imagine you guys feel that with this podcast too, right? Like you're actually where you are as opposed to being ahead or behind, which is really hard. Yeah, I'm still searching for that. Still every day trying to stay in the present moment.
It's not easy for me to not, you know, jump ahead. Will you talk to me about that? in the present moment. It's not easy for me, like, to not, you know, jump ahead. Yeah. Will you talk to me about that? Because I've always been told that, like, it's best to just stay in the present. But, like, my brain tells me... I know. But you go in there and your brain is like...
Like, I got plans, you know? And, like... Yeah. I've got plans. I've got a desire for the way I want this meeting to go or this That's so sweet, it's true you do you do going with that what do you but what are you supposed to do with that? What is that is that me inhaling a bomb inside your brain Yeah, it's just and then and then a little And then a little plan flies by like a bird like, pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
Yeah. That's a little plan. So am I just supposed to react to things and not drive anything? I don't know. It's a great question actually. I don't know because I'm struggling with that all the time. How much can I be prepared because that calms me down. Preparation calms me down.
But, you know, life, you cannot control. You cannot control things in life. I mean, it's just like you have to let go. You know what's a perfect example of that, J.B., today? When I just told you I sprained my foot really bad last night, it was so painful, I can't even describe it. And I woke, and my old me would have been like, oh my God, I gotta cancel painful, I can't even describe it. And my old me would have been like, oh my God, I gotta cancel this, I can't do this,
and I'm like, this is what it is right now, and I surrender to it, and I go, if I can't do this and I have to cancel that and I can't show up for it, then that's what it is. And it used to make me really depressed. I think that is one of the benefits I've been saying recently, I've been saying in therapy, that, oh, no applause.
I've been saying that- Oh, wait, Will, you're going, that's great. And you're 54. 54. Okay, very good. And what I've noticed at 54 is, and especially in the last six months, that it just kind of occurred to me,
I'm like, oh, I'm doing a much better job of, this is what the situation is, and I'm realizing it in real time, and I'm not really in a panic about the outcome, I'm just accepting it for what it is. And I said this to you the other day, like I got this notion of like, feelings are gonna come, feelings aren't gonna kill you,, feelings aren't gonna kill you,
your feelings aren't gonna kill you. That's a big one. And it really, and I went, oh yeah. And I can let it, I can feel it, and then I can let it go. And I can recognize, I think I used to, you know, you'd freak out and then you'd think about it later.
Now I can, in real time, go, oh, this is where I am. In a much better way than I, for me anyway, that I've ever been able to do. And I think that that's the benefit of being older, having experience, et cetera. I find my 50s to be my favorite decade by far. Yeah, yeah, it's pretty great. Oh really?
As you get to your 60s, it's pretty cool. I'm having a great time. No. Yeah. What if you guys find out, you see Jason's license one of these days and you find out he's 62. I thought about that the other day.
No, Willie, I like what you said about like not being attached to the outcome. Maybe that's a good hack for me. It's like, it's okay to be prepared, but don't be like stuck on it has to end this way. Yeah, again, it's a new concept for me. I've just been kind of going through it and it's very freeing.
Well, like Jason, for example, your mic hasn't been working this whole time and the audio hasn't recorded and you should be fine with that. Like just let that go. It's going to be great. It's a great episode and just let go of the outcome of that. Amy, any funny stuff happened on stage before with people?
Any funny stories? No, come on. Wait, Amy, why is 50 the best decade? I feel like I finally have a better sense of who I am. Kind of what we've been talking about. I have some of my priorities. I just feel like I'm a little kinder to myself. I definitely care less about how I'm perceived
by other people as long as I feel like my side of the street is clean. And I have a lot of wise people younger and older than me. Like I'm in this sandwich of experience. So I learn a lot from people younger and older than me. Like I'm in this sandwich of experience. So I learn a lot from people who are younger than me, and I learn a lot from people that are older than me, and knock on wood, I still feel healthy. Like being in your 50s,
you're like the youngest old person you know. You're the youngest of the old people. You're the freshmen of old people. That's really true. And so we'll never be this young again in our 50s because I'm looking to people in their 60s and 70s to see how they're living life, how they're doing it, how they're keeping healthy.
And then I still feel connected to people in their 20s and 30s. It doesn't feel so far away. I'm on medication to reverse the aging process. Ooh, what are you doing? I'll text you. I'll send it in the chat. I'll send it in the chat. You're that guy who does all those crazy things to stay and aging process. Ooh, what are you doing? I'll text you, I'll send it into the chat. I'll send it into the chat. You're that guy who does all those crazy things to like stay and super shape.
Oh my God, remember that? Oh that too, yeah. Did you watch that? Oh my God, that's wild. Wait, Amy, remember when you used to come over and we would watch Intervention? Oh my God, yes, Sean. We would airplay all the instruments
in the opening theme. Great theme, Intervention, what a great show. I know that show made me so uneasy. I wanted to tell the story, or for you to tell the story about remember the time that you told your friend that the TV was voice activated? Oh my God. Have you told that story?
I don't remember. Oh God. Well maybe, can I try to tell it? Yeah. Sean was with a bunch of friends, right? Yeah. Yeah, go ahead, Sean. No, no, I was just gonna help you out.
And you guys were really like- We would get stoned after- Get really stoned. After an episode, after taping an episode of Will and Grace and we went back to his house one night. Will and Grace, that's the show you were on. That's it. That is, that is.
Amy. You couldn't think of it? Yeah, Amy. Knock about our show. Never gonna get through it. This guy. A story that long will never make it on here. Go ahead, no, no, go ahead, don't tell it, it's good, it's really good.
Just bundle it. All right, well bundle it, bundle it. I'll try to bundle it. Okay, here we go. So we would go back after, we would get Stone, we'd just hang out and talk about the night and whatever after we tape an episode of Will and Grace. So we go to his house, it was a brand new house,
and he has a brand new house, he has a brand new media system, this massive screen in this screening room. And I'm high out of my mind, I can't even see straight, and he's trying, he goes, I just got the DVD of Castaway. We should watch it where the plane goes down because the effects are so cool, right? I'm like, yeah, let's put it on and watch it.
So he walks all the way to the front of the screening room and I'm way in the back and I start to giggle. He's like, what's so funny? I'm like, nothing. And he can't get it to play and I go, is that a Sony? And he goes, yeah. And I go, well, those are the new ones. You don't even know what you have, you're so rich, right?
They're voice activated. And he goes, what? And I go, those are voice activated new screens. Like you have to speak the name of the movie into the DVD player. And he goes, you're making that up. That's not even true. I go, those are the new screens.
You have to speak the name of the movie. and he totally bought it and he goes really close into the DVD player and he goes cast away And he looks at the screen and it didn't come up and the second time cast away And I couldn't believe. Me and Meredith Walker, we and Meredith Walker say cast away into our remote control a lot. No way. A lot. And into our DVD a lot. Cast away.
Cast away. Oh, Meredith, let's say hi to Meredith. Hi, D. Hi, Meredith. Hi, D. Are you guys still working together? It's a friend of all of ours, Meredith Walker. Yes, yes. Is she still in Austin? Yep, living in Austin.
Hey, oh, great. She's so great. We love Meredith. We love, love, love Meredith. Yeah, we say cast away quite a bit. Oh, that's great. I love telling someone something is voice activated when it isn't. I don't like a prank. I'm not a prank person at all.
You got it. For anybody to use. But that is a harmless funny prank. That is harmless. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Okay, so wait. Should I have any questions for Amy, your guest? It's okay, I mean, we don't need to.
No, no, this is minute 46. I don't think we've had a legit one yet. I know, I've asked her a couple ones. Really? Yeah. Yeah, I mean we don't need to. No, no, this is minute 46, I don't think we've had a legit one yet. I know, I've asked her a couple ones. Really? Yeah. Yeah, I mean, do we really need to, I mean, we should probably. No, it's a conversation.
Yeah, it's a conversation. Wait, wait, I do want to get into, you touched on it before, talk a little bit about when you were in Chicago, AIM and how you knew your experience in Second City, who was in that, when you were on the tour, you toured with second city and improv Improv olympic Chicago all that stuff and then how you how that moved to New York and UCB and all that stuff
I'm just I mean it is I'll bundle it because it is important as a storyteller to discuss You will get kicked off this podcast if you Telling a story and I love crafting story and I love my story craft to be about telling crafts. Oh, God. So, get used to it. The only thing we like on this podcast more than independent film is talking about independent film. Go ahead, Amy. LAUGHS
Started out in Chicago and arrived at Second City in 93 and the seniors to my freshmen were, on the main stage of Chicago, Amy Sedaris, Steve Carell, Stephen Colbert. Amazing. Mike Myers and Chris Farley had just left to go to like Stardom at SNL. I rented Chris Farley's old apartment.
In Chicago? In Chicago. I didn't know I was renting it, but you apartment. In Chicago? In Chicago. I didn't know I was renting it, but you know. In the Hancock building? No, it was another earlier one. Yeah, you know, back then in the 20s, when we were in our 20s and we moved every year, like remember moving every year.
Yes, that's true. And I think the apartment was probably like 390 a month and hard to make that rent. And then, yeah, studied and met Tina there very early on and met Rachel Dratch, who I was the understudy for at Second City. And it was just, the place was lousy with talent. Everyone was so great and then moved with, and then, and then UCB, Matt Besser, Matt Walsh, Ian Roberts, Ali Faranaki.
Oh, great guys, yes, yes, yes. Adam McKay, all those guys. Neil Flynn, they were all part of a big improv group called The Family that we would go and watch, and they were incredible. And then they also had UCB. I joined in 93, and then in 96, which is not that much time now that I think about it.
It was only three years, but we left and moved to New York, drove to the city, did a show, and just started. Well, at the time it was, well, I don't want this to be uncomfortable for you, but I was dating Matt Besser at the time, so it was a different relationship. I knew it, I fucking knew it! Yeah.
No, no, truly, I knew it. But here's the thing, here's a funny story and Amy knows this. So 96 and she knows how good I am with dates and this. Yeah, you're very good. 96 they come and they do UCB so it's Amy Walsh Besser and Ian and they do They do their show Bucket of Truth, which was an amazing show, it was so funny. It was a sketch show, improv and sketch, et cetera. And they're doing it downstairs at the West Bank on 42nd Street.
And Peter Principato, the beloved Peter Principato, who we all love. Yeah, manager. My first agent. First agent. William Morris. And Peter Principato, and he was my agent at the time, and he said to me, hey, I've just signed
this new comedy group, you've gotta go see them. They're performing at the time. And he said to me, hey, I've just signed this new comedy group. You've got to go see them. They're performing at the West Bank. So I went with Duff and Amy, I was dating Missy at the time. I don't know if I told you that. Oh, touche. You did, okay.
Yeah. So we go, the three of us to the West Bank, knowing nothing, go downstairs that little stage and watch them do Bucket of Truth and we're blown away. We go upstairs. You had not yet met Amy. Had not yet met.
We watched the show, we're blown away. We go for a drink after, we're talking about it. We talked about it for a few days because nobody was doing what they were doing. And we were like, God, that was so funny and it was so inventive and it was so cool and blah, blah, blah. So that is January of 1996.
And just like, what the fuck? Continue, sorry. Yeah, then we were there just slogging away and like Will said, and we remember this too, right? Like people had to come see you live. They had to go actually see you. We didn't have any, like, now you can really deep dive on someone really fast
on the internet, but we didn't have that. So you had to like go see people live. What was that first space you guys had when you started? We had a, Solo Arts was the name of a, yeah, was like the walk-up theater where we would improvise there and stuff, so we just kind of slogged for a while in New York and handed out flyers in Washington Square Park and everyone, I was a waitress and just thinking like, okay, you know,
and then I started getting some bits on Conan because of Andy Richter and that's where I got like my SAG card, that's where I got my, you know, I got paid like an under five. And now you're in the building though, right? Like was it, could you like taste the possibility of SNL perhaps? Did you allow yourself to start to dream that?
Mm-hmm. That's such a good question. I think you're right. I didn't really put that together, but you're right. Like walking in a 30 rock, you are, I always feel like with jobs and stuff, like Chicago felt like where I was getting my training, but New York and Los Angeles, it's almost like,
you know when you're having like a pickup game of basketball and someone's just standing around and you're like, hey, come play. Like, your- Sure, don't say sure. Your proximity to the game can be very helpful. Like getting closer to the game, just being around. So that's what happened.
When we moved to New York, we were just a little closer to the game. So we got asked to do things. And you're doing, and you're doing Bits on Conan and you did Andy's sister, Richter's sister, and you started doing more. And all those guys were there who were writers, a lot of whom were performers from Chicago.
You knew like McCann and Glazer and all those guys. Brian Stack, one of the all-time greats. And all those people, they're all there writing on Conan. And you guys are all kind of part of this group of people who are Creating comedy, right? Yeah, my decision to move to Chicago was probably the best decision For me in my career because it allowed me to meet all these people really fast who then went on to do things that I got To be a part of like I they remembered me for things. They put me in small things they, you know wrote things for me, and it was just this
concentrated feeling of comedy at the time that then everybody went to LA and New York, and McKay was the head writer of SNL, and Tina got a job there. We all just started, it was really, really cool to, and I depended on the kindness of a lot of those people for a long time to have a job. Let me ask you a tough question,
and I'll try to bundle here. Basically, it's basically after all of the accomplishment, you've just walked us through the whole beginning and everything, it just seems like you've done, or maybe even far exceeded, what you allowed yourself to dream of at that age when you were starting. What's left? What would you love to do in your next,
you know, now that you're a freshman? Why do you still get out of bed, Amy? What do you want? Yeah, I mean, you've done it. You've had this incredible career already and you're still, as you said, a freshman. Like, where would you love, how would you like to use what you've done,
the success you've had? Bundle, bundle. Yeah, sorry, go ahead. Well, that would you like to use what you've done, the success you've had? Bundle. Yeah, sorry, go ahead. Well, I am, that's why I'm starting to wind down and this podcast is the beginning of that. Like, I'm just starting to wind down away from showbiz. Hang on a second, hey, truly? Yeah, yeah.
Fucking cool. Just to be cool. Are you being weird or no? No, no, no, we're the number two most downloaded podcast on the planet, so just know your gent. No, no, her podcast she's talking about. Oh yeah, that is a wind down, you're right. That is a wind down.
No, or are you talking about us? Well, you know what? It remains to be seen. It remains to be seen. But no, no, but honestly, it is kind of why I'm excited to do a podcast, because I'm actually, Jason, to genuinely answer your question,
I am excited about what is the next, I like thinking about what is the next thing to do. Like I like trying new things, that's what keeps me feeling engaged in the world and in our creative. So I'm very excited about this new podcast because I really like, I'm a huge fan of podcasts in general. I listen to them all the time and they really replaced a lot of like media for me and I'm into the idea of exploring it
because I really like talking to people and I'm curious about people and I learn a lot about myself and I like to have fun. I think what's happened in the space, especially for women, is that women are being asked to be teachers and wise leaders and they don't get to fuck around and do very little research like you guys. You know that?
You guys do not know who the guest is, which is the wildest con in the world. It's unbelievable. By the way, you could have bundled that insult. That would have been a lot nicer. But let me ask you a tough question. You know, Sean, shut up for one second. Shut the fuck up.
Fuck. Amy, Amy, answer this question honestly. This is a tough one. This is a hard hitting, all right? And I know you're very serious for a comedian, so that's okay. Her mom used to say that to her when they get into arguments. When we get in a fight, she'd say, you're so serious for a comedian. So, wait, have you ever listened to Smartless?
Of course I have. Okay, you have. That's a little high. I've listened to Smartless. She could go up on that. I'm pretty sure, what are you talking about? Of course I have, oh my God, I love, my favorite episode is the one with the lady
and the other one with the guy. I love the one with the guy. Oh my God. Oh, I like the one with the Bradley. But so, in your answer to my unbundled question, it sort of gets into the area of there is a slight plan, but you still want to kind of stay in the present and not be too sort of strategic about what the next five, ten years are, right?
So like, how do you find the balance there? I guess it's just figuring out, it's just kind of figuring out So like, how do you find the balance there? I guess it's just figuring out, it's just kind of figuring out what feels challenging. I like a challenge. So I like mixing things up to feel challenging. And also a big part of my 50s has been balancing my relationship to work in general and how do I make sure that there's real balance in my life.
Like the last five years you guys were talking about being on your podcast. Stuff that's not challenging potentially, right? Exactly. Just relaxing, yeah. Yes, like basically how to find ease and enjoy, the past five years have been wild. Wild.
And you know, what you guys do here, what I've been doing is just like trying to just genuinely laugh with my friends. It's been actually, you know, how I've been keeping sane. And so I want to just do whatever feels like that, which feels kind of fun and a little bit challenging. And so I'm always trying to figure it out. I don't know, it's a long-winded answer.
I don't know. No, but it makes total sense. It's basically a combination of all the things. And you're able to combine now because you're older and smarter and wiser and it doesn't have to be like all go on career or all go on just like no, fuck it, I don't want to do anything.
We're actually able to merge both now, finally, at this age, I think. And women, I think, especially, have often a burden to really pay attention to what everybody is doing and feeling, and then if you have the luxury of turning it around and trying to figure out yourself, it's like, that is what can be great about getting older
and women do really well, I think, when they give themselves time to do that. Let me speak to that. Let me speak about women. Yeah, let's talk about women. So. But we'll go ahead. Your thoughts on women?
Ha ha ha ha. But Amy, who is that person that you bounce stuff off of or when you get like? I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. have been through it with me, I think, is really the biggest resource for me. You know, people who have kids and people who, you know, who understand what it's like to feel overwhelmed and stuff, and especially the past five years, which has just been a complete insane hit after hit of sci-fi nightmares.
Right. That's a dream of mine. Totally. But what, what's it like, what's it like being for you and Will being on the verge of being empty nesters? It's not the verge, but it's gonna, it's gonna come sooner than later. Do you think about that? And like. I do.
How that relates to what you're gonna do? I know. I know, I haven't really, but kind of in the short story metaphor, I haven't, I'm like, I don't feel like the the story that I'm there yet. So yeah quite yeah, I don't know I mean, it's it feels so It's I don't even know it's yeah, I got one about to go to college and it's how does it feel? It's bleak, you know, because there's just it it it there. It's so it's a mortality thing
It's like it's you know, we know, we all kick it down the road. Oh, it's about you. Well, but it's like, it's the concept of the end of something that is just something is conveniently kind of pushed aside, and then it's here. Can I say something about that that I've noticed? And this is, JB, I've learned from you something that,
and I mean this gently and I mean this sweetly, which is- This is gonna hurt. No, which is, you've been, Jason's been so nervous and anxious about Franny going to college for a few years and he's talked about it. And so I see him going through the pain for so long
and this is an example of not living in the present. So sometimes I think that you had a tough time enjoying the moment because you're just so, you've been anticipating for years, you've been putting that out and talking about it. And I'm trying to separate myself from her so it doesn't hurt. Yeah, exactly. Which is by the way, which is so you like, remember you do that. Like Jason's thing to not laugh when he's in a take is to think about people dying in a car crash. I'm not kidding. And then he doesn't. And then he won't go up. Right?
Well, we all know. We all do that. We all know Jason is sociopathic to this. No, he's a robot. But the thing is, but I see that in you and I've said it to you before, I'm like, it's okay, let that moment come when that moment comes and enjoy. So I've been using it, I keep reminding myself, just enjoy it now, enjoy it now.
It's, again, not easy. It is not easy. No. It's a great no. Well, raise your hand if you think you're gonna live to 100 and if you wanna live to 100. That's me. Okay, three of us are raising our hands. Sean is not raising, it's that ankle.
Sean's like, I can't go on with that ankle. I can't, with this ankle, no way. No, I'm done. The ankle was the last straw. I think we got a shot. Yeah, no, it's really, didn't one of these really smart scientists lately say that the person that's going to live to 120 or 150 or something
is already born? Like that's gonna be kinda common in this generation. Like 100 is like the new 80s. Yeah, but what kind of life do you have at 120? Yeah, Sean, I hear you. Like as long as it feels like a fruitful life. But you know, imagine if you were like a little dude in a cute little suit.
And you got wheeled around. Like in the news, like the local news, they cut to like, Marjorie is 106 today, and we visited her, and she can't talk or move. And they're like, Marjorie, Marjorie, what advice do you have for people to live this long? And she's like, make sure that you're here. And she's got cake falling out of her mouth.
Every day. Yeah, exactly. Please walk in, have a glass of wine and... Exactly, I don't want to be that. I don't want to be Marjorie. Remember Ernest Borgnein had that great, he had this great advice on how to live forever, which was to snap one off every day. Oh, he did? Yeah, and you know where he lived?
In Jason and Amanda's house. And so I always reminded him to think about Ernest Borgnein walking around that house. Just throwing goo all over the place. He had Borgnein lives actually. Oh, nice, very nice. Beautiful. Thanks guys.
Amy, I have one last comment before we let you go because we've had you for too long and I want to thank you for your time. Thank you, Sean. I told you, and both you and Will, I love Archie and Abel so much and I love Maple and Franny too. Everybody on this podcast right now.
You guys have done such a phenomenal job between your journey between you two, your kids are just unbelievable, great human beings. And it's the greatest compliment to you guys. I just love them and you guys. And I wanted to remind people to listen to Good Hang with you. Thank you, it's on Spotify.
And I have great guests coming out. Tina Fey is my first guest. No kidding. That's great. Yep, because you know, give America what they want. And then get Dax on there. Dax will give you some pointers. Yeah, Dax would be great.
Can't wait. Yeah, any pointers guys, now that you're five years in? You can tell we've learned nothing. Yeah, zero. We're last people. I mean, if you guys can do it. It's true, anybody can do it. By the way, Amy, you won't be surprised that we haven't
looked at comments forever, they'd always be like, their questions suck and they interrupt people all the time and I'm like, yeah, of course we do. What are you talking about? If you guys have taught me anything and taught all individually and collectively taught me so much, it's Don't overthink it. Don't overthink it. It's good. Unbelievable. We love you so much. We finally got you.
We love you, Amy. Thanks, guys. Thanks for having me on. It was so fun. Thank you, Amy. Okay, glad it was a fun surprise. Thanks, guys. It was such a good surprise.
I'm bringing the boys over. Okay. Can't wait. Bye. Bye, Amy. Thank you. Yeah, you got it. My pleasure.
Bye. Bye. Bye, can't wait. Bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Bye, Aym, thank you. Yeah, you got it, my pleasure. So, well, that was fantastic to meet her. I've been such a fan of hers for, I don't know. Yeah. How funny.
I had no, you know what, when you were doing the intro, and of course I was like, and then she was like, oh, you didn't, I was like, it never occurred to me. You just thought it was coincidental that all, oh, well, you know, Amy did all those things. How did you guess it, Jay? From what? Because you said a queen of Massachusetts
or something like that. Oh, wow, you knew it just like that. Yeah, but I still, I had such a like, yeah. I love that you didn't know. I told Amanda last week. Oh, yeah. And yeah, she's like, oh. Amanda could work for the government.
She is very good about keeping a secret. But the kids, Abel's here right now. He never said a word. I love that. God bless him. I love your face. I'm gonna go drag him out of his bed. How dare you?
That was right. Listen, it's not to get weird, but I hope you're as proud as you should be, and she as well. I mean, like, that went beautifully. Like, the fact that you guys not only have raised these two kids so well, but your relationship is so great and healthy and like, you could do a fucking one hour
podcast in front of millions of people and not have to fake anything. Like, it's just, you know, it's pretty admirable. I know it took, like full disclosure, like any couple that goes through the journey you've gone through, it took a while, but you're there now. Yeah, but you know, I am really proud of it. And of course it takes, things take a minute
because everybody's sort of adjusting to what it is, but I'm also very proud of, certainly as parents, what we've been able to do. And that, you know that has been really important to both of us. And yeah, I'm really, really lucky to have her as a partner in this way for us to parent this way. How lucky Archie and Abel are too, that you guys like worked out a brand new relationship
that serves you both and them. And it's- And I would say that I probably, you know, there aren't many people I speak to more than I speak to her, which is weird because, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. But it's great. I feel really lucky and I do still-
Does Josh Shotlin get jealous at all or? He does, but she is somebody that I still run a lot of stuff by if I'm thinking of her. Does who get jealous? If Josh is not available. He's my buddy Josh that I FaceTime with. Oh, Josh, I didn't hear what you said, yeah. But I still, she's the person I go like,
hey, I'm thinking about doing this, or hey, whether it's life or work, and I really, I seek her counsel because it's important to me, because I trust her in that. Yeah, and she's a sharp cookie. She's awesome, she's awesome. What was the buy from the opening?
It was a bicentennial, 250 episodes. That's right. So anyway, so guys, that was unbelievable and enjoy the rest of your day. No, it's our 250th episode, I can't believe it. That was unbelievable and enjoy the rest of your day. No, it's our 250th episode. I can't believe it. Wait, what?
Yeah. You remember 1976. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was the 200th. That was the... Bye! San Antonio! Everybody! everybody. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael
Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. SmartLess Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.